From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Good morning.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013.
My name is Dr. Asan Kwanbi-Jeffries of Ohio State University in Southern Illinois,
a history program at the University of North Carolina and Chapel Hill,
I'm with the Oliver Burr at Nileego in Albany, Georgia, on the campus of Albany State University.
They conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture and the Library.
We are here with Dr. Clifford, David, Cliff Browner, Jr.
Thank you so much.
I want to begin this conversation on discussion here with some background information.
Mr. Browner, could you tell us when and where you were born?
Born to me, seven, seven, seven, seven, six, and Georgia, that's in Terracalty.
And your parents, what were their names?
My father's name was Clifford.
My mother's name was Johnny Lou.
And where were they born?
My father was born in Webster County and my mother was born in Terracalty.
Webster's a few miles north of Terracalty.
Do you know how they met?
I remember her telling me a story.
She was at school one day and it was right after her mother had passed
and her grandmother sent her to the woodpile to get wood.
And she prayed to the Lord to send her somebody that would love her and care for her.
And she said she went to school the next day my father set behind her.
She said never said anything to her before.
But this particular day after she prayed, he touched on the shoulder and asked if she thought her grandmother
would mind if he came to see her.
And that's how they started.
You said they met in school?
How long were they able to go to school?
How much schooling did they get?
I believe my father told me he completed 3 grade and my mother was about 8 grade.
I believe it's correct.
Your father, he was a sharecropper.
No, or did he work the land?
He started out sharecropping.
And I think by the time I was failure those he came off of the farm and took a job in Albionist.
He swiped for a lasso, complained.
And that's what he retired from.
So you worked there for a number of years?
Yes.
And how far was Albionist from your home?
A roughly 20 miles.
Did you find as a child growing up that you would often go to Albionist or did you tend to stay more around your home in Saftler and Terrell?
Well there were occasions when weekends in particular that he would bring us to the zoo in Albion.
And that was a fun day.
And this of course was segregated, right?
Yeah, it was still segregated.
So what was your experience like coming to Albionist at that time?
Well actually, I didn't actually run into much segregation in the sense of the word because my father kept us shielded from that to a point.
Now we knew it existed but nobody really bothered us as a family.
So some of the things that you would hear about the sound I really didn't experience because of that protection that he put in force.
And by protection, how did he do that?
What do you mean that nobody bothered you because of this protection?
Well one thing, if we went in place, I'm going to have to go.
So, I think we worked during the summer.
We could only work if she worked in the same place we worked.
So you made sure that we were always looked after.
And I never had the opportunity to work for fights in the year.
I couldn't crash or couldn't head just to things like that.
He didn't allow us to do that because he wasn't there to look after it.
So he made sure we stayed home and let my mother could actually be there.
So I never really had any really confrontations per se as a child in that respect.
What was the community like that you grew up in?
The black community.
If you sheltered from sort of being exposed to white working in that,
what was the community like that you were exposed to that you were growing up in?
Well we basically lived in all black communities of course.
There were dirt streets and the houses that didn't have paint.
And most of them were three room houses.
And of course there were varied numbers of family members living in our case.
There were extended family members there.
So the community itself was basically black.
And we didn't have any real control of what went on.
So if you learn how to live within that city,
you avoid it trouble.
But for lack of a better way of putting it stand in your place.
So there were differences.
If we went outside that we knew there were ways we were supposed to care ourselves.
In front of whites we were just certain of certain, yes ma'am, no ma'am,
what it was spoken to.
And how did you pick up on those?
Is this something that your mother said that you have to do?
How did you learn those particular ways to interact with white folks?
Well some of us started home and some of you picked up from interactions.
You saw other people do certain things and you just followed suit.
And you weren't the only child.
Your parents had how many children total?
I have four of us.
Two boys, two girls, two sisters, two sisters older and my brothers,
I was in their child.
But my mother raised and father raised over the children.
I had a cousin at Lywoodville saying,
her mother at some point and my mother raised her baby sister and brother
from her mother's marriage.
So you had a four household as you were saying.
You grew up with a house full of people.
And I thought there was always somebody there that really wasn't an out immediate family.
All through my teenage life growing up.
So my family always took care of my cousin and some other people.
And there were instances where even brother and mother were living with us at some point.
Now what elementary school did you go to?
The elementary school that I attended was done by elementary school.
And it's the building that side is the other end of the building that's been torn down.
And what was done by life?
Done by life.
White, maybe I should say, it had been white.
But, you know, well it had faded in so it was a dull looking white building.
There weren't any indoor facilities with heated by a pot-bending stove in the middle of the room.
And you know, you went to one class, you pre-med stayed there,
you teach and talk to everything from that classroom.
We asked children to go out on the head road, we called it,
to cut wood to start to fire in the stoves.
And there were underneath the, what we were called a crawl space now.
The coal was still underneath the building.
So we were going under the building, under the building.
And we were going to go out with buckets and a shovel to get coal green and to keep the fire going and the stove doing the one-a-tang.
So this is what you and your classmates would do, yes.
And of course, when you, the facilities were outside, they had two facilities, one for the boys, one for the girls, I say.
There were no indoor facilities, no running water.
And did your siblings also go to Dunbar as well?
They, they, they may not have because they were older.
You know, because I don't know if that's been a long while back.
So some things I don't remember specifically, but they may not have gone there as much as I did because I was young and the young's one of them.
Now did you stay in Dunbar all the way up until high school?
No, actually the first Dunbar, they built a new school in, I think, 1955.
And after that, I, I left there and went to Carver, which is the Dundhsendjurge, which is called High School, the Dundhsendjurge.
And I think I went to eighth grade from Dunbar.
And how far was Carver? I mean, because that was a little bit further away from where you lived.
Seven miles. And how did you get to school bus?
Yeah, we were bus from Sassar. Bus would come to Dunbar, pick it up.
They would do actually pick the ones up in the country, bring them to Dunbar, then they would lead there and go to Carver.
And thinking about the kind of education that you would see, the quality of education, reflecting back on it.
I mean, what did you, how would you say it was?
You feel that you got a good foundation, that it was just as good as anything you could have gotten.
What would you say?
Well, first of all, I believe that if you apply, you said, wherever you are, you would get a good education.
But also, you know, we weren't exposed to a lot of stuff.
So it wasn't in theory in that sense that we just didn't get exposed to things that were in other places.
The education, teach the work and serve it in the value.
And what they were able to teach you, they wanted you to learn that.
But, you know, I still say that in the end of this one in theory education.
Did your parents talk much about school to you growing up?
They are concerned with that we would get an education because they knew that we were the key to a better life.
So, you know, we never had to stay out of school to work.
That was one of the advantages of my father not being on the phone.
The insistent that we go to school.
So, when the other children had to stay out because they were crossing the field, we didn't have to.
So, that was the advantage I saw of him not being on the phone.
Now, your mother, what does she do for the...
Did she work outside of the home?
She did, they labor her domestic laborer.
She worked, she cooked, took care of the white's babies and clean house.
And eventually she worked at the white elementary school that was in SAS as a cook.
And eventually she went to, from there to Donbar when they were able to be on the new school.
When they had lunchroom, she worked in that lunchroom and then eventually she took a tat and then lunchroom and call her.
Now, she was working at SAS, when did she begin working at the white school, at the white school?
She worked in the white school during the time I was in school so I don't know the year but it was like it would have been in the fielder.
So now, when the sort of protests begin, so the civil rights protests begin in Albany in early 1960s, 1961.
In terror a little bit later, in really 1963.
You're still young, you're not in high school yet, are you?
Yes, you are in high school.
So when things begin in Albany first, were you aware of them?
How did you become aware of them?
Do you remember hearing about them at all?
The first time you began hearing about things going on?
My father and my father were involved, my system was involved.
Older, one older, one older, one older sister was involved.
So that's how I knew about the movement.
I didn't initially start out attending mass meetings but that came later as they moved the mass media to the church where we remember.
And that church was my own out of the church in SAS.
Now, about my own out of it, that was your family's church?
Yes.
Was it a big church, big membership, small church?
For that time, it was a medium, so I think a membership church for that time.
There were four other churches, a five other churches in SAS and Facility.
And I think we met on full Sundays.
Only on the full Sundays at Mount Olive, once a month.
Now, were your parents active in the church?
And your church groups, church memberships?
My dad, I know worked in finance.
I mean, I can remember as a young and child in money.
So I know he worked in finance.
I don't know if he lived with chairman, mother decimble, but I know he was decimble there and I know he worked in finance.
And he can make past a trustee working in finance.
They didn't call it that bank, right?
Yeah.
He was responsible for getting the money to the bank and that kind of thing.
And how about your mother?
My mother, I don't remember her holding an office in church doing that time.
Because they held membership in two different churches actually.
But she attended Monalda frequently.
People really thought she was a member of Monalda, but she actually was a member of Santa's gift baptism church, which is about two or three miles from where we lived.
But she was always at Monalda, so nobody ever questioned whether she was a member of that.
Now, your church memories are they Monalda's church memories?
Do you remember attending Monalda's?
Yes, I did.
You know, like, southern schools, east of plays, singing in a church choir.
You know, in the choir board, there's more than singing in the choir.
Now, how important was that church life to you and your family?
Well, it was a thing that we believed in doing.
We believed that God, we needed God in our lives.
And we attended church very often.
It wasn't like we went once, we went to every two or three months, and we went every month to that church.
And occasionally, I would go with my mother to Santa's gift.
So church life was important to us.
That church was my father a little bit of church.
And, you know, one of the requests he made before he died was that for me not to let church die.
So that's how important it was to him.
So, do you recall at all any of the conversation that went into deciding that the church should open its doors to a mass meeting, to the movement when it begins organizing in the teller county?
Well, I wasn't privy to a conversation of that soul, but I know that they had been meeting that Zion grow, I believe, a Zion heal, which was in Stereocardi but out from Carlson.
And I was told from conversation that the people in that area was not attending the meeting.
So, they moved into the sassages of the Monata because that's what the book of the people were coming from that were going to the Zion.
And the fact that pastors aren't here that time lived in sassages, so they brought into Monata where it was closer to the majority of the people who were attending.
So, that's, you know, pretty much the reason that they moved in.
And you remember some of the mass meetings at Monata?
At Monata, yes.
What were they like? What were they like?
They were excited meetings. I mean, you know, people, the first time I really saw blacks and whites intermingling in a close vicinity that way was at those meetings.
And there was spirit feeling all the times, there were scriptures read, conversations about what went on in other areas of Thereocardi or Lee County,
and Lee County, on Dirty, were brought back on those meeting nights.
And you hear who had been beaten up or who had been arrested or, you know, who had a confrontation with the Sheriff Department or police or whatever.
Those kind of things came back.
And what kind of results was they were getting in their mess and they are voter registration drives.
So, they were person stories told along with the singing.
And so, now you were younger. I mean, you were only about 15, 16.
So, you could have two young and registered a vote.
Right.
So, what were some of the things that you were thinking about doing?
And at the time, in addition to attending the mass meeting, were you doing any other activities or what sort of the mass meeting really kind of the focus of your activity?
Well, the mass meeting really wasn't focused in a lot of ways, but at school, Clovis Jones and I wrote a letter to the superintendent.
And I can't remember his name at this time, but we wrote a letter to him asking for new books because the one we were getting were hamming down from the white school.
And of course, Paige were missing in there and during the notes written in them, you know, those kind of things.
And they were getting the new books and then we were getting the old books.
And this is why you went high school.
So, Clovis, it started out about five of us sat down to write the letter when the time to send the letter on the Clovis and I sat there.
And of course, we got in trouble with the press from school.
Now, did you let your parents know beforehand that you were writing this letter?
No, I never mentioned the level of being written.
They found out about the letter actually had the mass meeting actually.
And what did they say when they, I don't recall any reaction about it.
You know, they didn't, I didn't get scolded for doing it.
Let's put it that way.
And it was talked about in the meetings about that.
We paused just for some technical difficulties, but we're just going to pick right back up.
Where we had left off, you were talking about the letter that you had written to the school superintendent that only you yourself and Clovis Jones signed.
Did anything come of it?
We were called into the principal's office and we were threatened.
By the principal?
Did you recall the principal's name?
The E.E.S.S.
And this is the second-guided school.
This is all black school.
All black school.
And what did he say?
He said that we should be put out of school.
Simple as that.
And he did not put us out of school, but he said that we should be put out of school.
Why?
Because apparently the superintendent had gotten on him because the letter came his office from us at his school.
And he was responsible for us.
So I'm assuming that the superintendent had words with him about it.
And so how did that make you feel?
You're standing up for what you know is right and you could call them to the principal's office and you're reprimanded.
At the time, I didn't feel it was fair.
I thought that he should have been a part of what we were doing.
But as I got older, I understood what he didn't do anymore in our favor.
Why was that?
Because when you have a family and obligations, you look at things a lot different when you don't have obligations.
If that was happening now, at my age, I don't know if I would take the same stand, too.
But I don't know if I would have been any different about the letter.
I would have suggested that it should have come to me with it rather than going to the superintendent.
But I understand his point now.
I mean, I hold up the gist up for that.
So afterwards, you write the letter and you get called into the principal's office.
And what did you do next?
Well, we were treated differently at school than after that.
Treated by who?
Other faculty members, we were told that we were frightened of the students and those kinds of things.
And they would watch us doing recess periods.
We would have recess back in those days.
So who outside?
They would keep the hours.
And actually, I was president of senior class.
And they forced me to resign.
They didn't take it from me, but they put it to me in a way that I knew what they wanted me to do.
And they were excited that it's brilliantly glenched behind that letter.
And how about your classmates, how do they respond?
Because clearly, people knew that you had written this letter.
Nobody questioned.
The students, the few that were involved, were involved, and the ones that were not.
I mean, they didn't question what was going on with their new ideas.
How did you do that?
How can we get involved?
They stayed away from us a lot.
Some of them didn't participate with us.
So they were the people's people we were putting in.
Because of that.
Did you see some of your classmates at Mass meetings?
Ah, yes.
They were classmates there.
Emma Robertson is the one that lived next door to her.
She was a classmate of mine.
Doug Nesette, what's the gravity of what's a classmate of mine?
He attended the meetings.
And I'm thinking a young lady named Edith Page attended on occasions.
Those are the ones that can remember right up here in the middle of the classmate's play.
And to go back to the Mass meetings at Mount Olive, your home church.
They begin in summer of 1962.
Is that some of them?
I don't, I can't.
Okay.
The verify had the exact time they started.
But they move over to your home church Mount Olive and you have any Mass meetings going on there.
And then one night late that summer, Mount Olive is targeted and burned to the ground.
That's correct.
When did you hear about the arching?
My uncle who lives in sight of the church, you can see the church where my grandparents lived.
He lived.
So the fire came to my day at his house and woke us up.
So we went to the church that night.
But prior to that, a lot of whites came into the church with guns, including the sheriff of the county.
And you know, doing the one of the Mass meetings.
And they walked around and in blooded us a little bit.
But nobody was out of can't think of anybody being struck or being nor.
But just insulted and quiet ways.
And you were there?
Yeah, I was there.
What did you think?
I mean, you see the sheriff coming in?
Had you had any interaction with the sheriff before?
No.
Any of the deputies?
No, they had not.
And this is the county sheriff?
Yes, from the county.
He and his deputies, I guess, and other citizens or the white citizens.
They were not dressed in white rolls and they got a sub of it.
They don't ring with clothes.
But they had their pistols and guns.
Do you recall the sheriff's name?
ZT Matthews is what we call him.
He was the sheriff's name.
Phil Sambri, and I wasn't afraid that night.
I don't really know why, but I wasn't afraid that night.
And I remember every year, I read from Rome at 8.
That night.
Charles Sambri.
Who's next?
It go out before it could be a kiss.
And then show that the chick would burn it.
That night when you go with your father.
And you literally see the church in Columbus.
Actually, it was the morning.
The church was burned down by the time my father and I got the church was burned to the ground.
The actual stills smothering.
And there were hot spots.
But I can remember sitting on the ground and you can see if anybody would burn a church there, do anything.
And that was one of the statements I remember saying to myself, as I stood in the watch, the smoke.
Do you remember your father's reaction?
He was hurt.
I don't remember any conversation, per se, but I know he was hurt about it.
How about others in the community?
What did church members say?
What was the sentiment?
As a child, we were not in conversation with adults a lot about things.
I mean, when adults talk, we kind of push this out, but totally go play.
So some things I didn't hear because of that rooming.
But I don't remember any real conversation with any church members about it, but I know they were hurt too.
And I remember working with two of the deacons doing the tabby, church being reconstructed.
But as far as conversation about, I wish we had not of that kind of thing.
I never heard any of that from anybody.
I'm not saying they didn't happen, but I never heard it.
Was your father or your family ever concerned?
I mean, your father's active in the church had just been burned down.
Oldest is very active in the movement.
Was there ever any concern for your family's personal safety?
Yes, there were always concerns about that.
In fact, I heard rumors that they were talking about burning out house,
but there was older folks who lived close to us who were not involved, and they didn't want to harm them.
So that's the reason I heard that they didn't burn out house.
And I remember my day at the making statement that one of the white women tried to run him off the road as he was going to all get into work one morning.
So that was three of us, I guess I feel.
Did your father take any, or your mother, or any other family members take any precautions in case threat materialized?
Not of any grave nature.
I mean, they were vigilant in watching.
But other than that, I don't think of anything that we actually did.
We didn't go out and buy guns or that kind of thing.
And that's what you ask.
And no, nothing I remember.
On that level.
No more than being vigilant.
And we were, I can remember being a little bit more restricted from going places at that point.
In terms of where you're in terms of the things, what I'm going to do with you, kind of being out of eyesight.
So after, was there any conversation among, or reaction among, kids your age after these series of churches burned down?
Because schools just about to begin, right?
Because this happened sort of late summer.
Do you recall anything, any talk among those kids at all?
No, no, none.
The kids that we involved with involved.
And we basically just about the man's meat and we enjoy them.
And that was pretty much the conversation.
Nothing about the church per se, or, you know, evil or that kind of thing.
Nobody, I don't remember the conversation.
I could do the body.
Now, when you do very well in high school, but then when you graduate,
you decide to join the army.
Yes.
What was behind that decision?
Well, one thing my father could not afford to send me to college.
He and I had the conversation one morning said, you know, baby, I just can't afford to pay for college.
I said, don't worry about that, I take care of it.
And at the time the reproducibility coming in, you know, for the military.
And I set for the exam, passed the exam.
And my cousin, one of my cousins, picked two of the exam as well.
And a couple other people that I can remember them.
My cousin in past exam, that's what he didn't go.
But I remember him, see Ferguson and Clare Foster were class weeks now.
We went in at the same time, we took our base of training at the same time.
And the college staying came about.
The military was an option for me because I thought I could save money for college.
And that's why I joined the military.
And so this was 1964.
Yeah, okay.
July of 1964 was when I actually went into the military.
And what did you do your basic training, full goal in Georgia and my advanced training was at full block in Turkey.
What did you think about leaving home?
Was this your first time sort of an extended time, first extended time away from Sausler and Terrell County?
Actually, this is the second time I ever spent a night out of my mother's house.
The first time I was actually at the very, now I can say, the first time was to March on Washington.
I went to Washington, to the March on Washington.
So I was waiting.
The second time I went to Atlanta for the physical form of my military exam.
And then, going to the end.
So actually, I never spent any time out of my mother's house.
I was in the middle of the except for those three.
Well, let's back up for a quick second.
So I do want to come back to the military experience.
But the March on Washington, how do you wind up going up to Washington, D.C.?
And this is August of 1963. How does that happen?
Or a Rivershire Arcane to be an instrument if I wanted to go.
And he said, I have a ticket for you.
But at the time, I was working on the church, working on Monado out of here, helping to rebuild the church.
That was my first job I ever had where I made an out of the wage.
Before that, you were paid by the day or by the poundage.
If you know what we paid for, we paid $200.
You were paid for $100 pounds of cotton, you got $2.
I remember working on the streets of Salsa with a guy named Charlie Jiren, who dragged seed, grabbed seeds.
And he paid us five hours of labor for him to see bad and drag those kind of things.
Charlie Jiren.
He was a wake-up.
He had a seed business on the streets of Salsa.
But working with a church, I think, Mississippi, I was paying us $1.40 an hour.
And that was the first hour of the wage I ever earned.
And I worked with him on all three churches that were buried during that time.
And during the time the church would be in Bill, you know, I earned money.
I had money earned enough to go to Washington to have my own spending money.
But the ticket would be provided for the train.
You left the other tea stall on the train.
And took it out to DC.
Yes.
I think the jacks would be a freshman and would have the course.
I think the switch was the route.
So that's your first train ride?
First train ride.
Do you remember it?
Yeah.
When we left here, it was warm.
So unfortunately, I didn't have a jacket.
Black slacks, white shirts, slugs, and shell-seed spirit.
And when I get to Washington, of course, it's cold.
So that was the experience.
I hadn't thought about the season of the Weller being that different, you know,
because we didn't have a TV radio communication with limited.
We didn't read newsfavorites for the Pittsburgh career.
And we didn't get those often.
So I had no concept about what the weather was like in place else.
And you know, since we're all this year, I thought the weather was the same there.
And nobody told me.
You know what I knew.
And my family didn't know, I guess, because my mother insisted on taking a jacket.
Now, did you go by yourself?
Yes.
Just solely just me.
And so you arrive in at a train station in DC.
And how do you make your way over to the mall?
Well, we all went in a group.
You know, it was a group of people that left here together.
I had seen some of them from the movement, but not really friends.
I didn't have any personal friends on the train with me.
So pretty much that was a long one.
So we got a train station.
We enmeshed with to the mall.
And from that, from one event to the other until we heard the speech.
Now, what were you doing over the course of the day?
Just walking.
Based on walking and then listening.
All to be among that many people.
You know, never seen that many people in one place at one time.
It was an experience.
And to hear the bands that played and the speeches that were given.
And to see people who were full of famous, but you may not know them by name.
The conference I believe with that Peter Paul and Mary, I think.
And Dr. King, the speech, of course.
And just a Jackson's, some other people that I reckon that's from.
Coming in out doing a movie.
John Lewis and John Lewis.
But other than that, you know, I was pretty much alone.
Just enjoying the day.
For what it was worth.
Had no idea the impact that we were making.
Had I known how important that day was, I would have saved some of the buttons
of those kind of things that were there.
So I'll have any of that in one of the members of it.
And so after, I, I, I, I afterward, all right.
I mean, you the, the, the, the speeches are done on the mall.
And it's just time to go, you just pack up and head on.
We just go back to the train because we didn't take luggage.
We go back to the train.
You don't train coming home.
Just to train right.
That's about it.
What do you think of Washington DC?
This is much of it, except for the, you know, the part.
Because there were so many people you could only see with,
right in front of you actually and most of the time there was somebody that says back.
So as far as the money and the money and so on, you really didn't get to see that in
the sense of the word, not to actually enjoy it.
You just knew that they were there.
That's all.
When people curious about your experience when you came back home, I really, nobody
really asked.
Does that really remember asking me, you know, how was it or what did you learn or got
thing to what asked?
Now, had you seen King before, down here?
I remember him coming to my daughter doing the time to church at Burmese,
standing on the ground there.
That was the first, I think, the only time I could saw him in person like that.
Well, that actually had that church at the Burmese.
So watching the DC was on the first time you spent the night away from your mother's home,
on the out from under your mother's roof.
Second time you go up for the physical, please.
Third time, you're not coming back, right?
I mean, you're about to, you're in the army.
What was basic training like?
Basic training was fun, actually.
I played basketball in high school, so I was still in shape.
And, you know, I wasn't intimidated.
Basic training was, it was rigorous but fun.
I learned a lot out of two.
I like to say I was timid a little bit before that.
And it helped me to kind of redefine my personality.
And it was a good thing for me, I think.
Matter of fact, I believe that all young men on a health be able to spend those two years
minus the war thing, of course.
You know, but it's a good training ground for young men.
It helped me get a footing as to be responsible for them,
say, or the need to be in the work with a group of people,
and take orders and be responsible for the people.
Now, your unit wasn't mostly black, black and white mixed,
mixed, Spanish, American, you know, Puerto Ricans.
Now, was this your first time in a group that was as racially diverse as that?
Yes.
What'd you think?
I mean, here you coming from rural?
I never thought about it in a way.
I mean, it wasn't like I had any special regard or special concerns.
You know, you just, you do what you're supposed to do,
and you demand to be respectful space.
And that's pretty much it.
And you respect that as well.
So I didn't see that as a problem.
Actually, it was a good experience.
And where are you stationed?
Afterwards, you finished basic training,
and then they sent you where to Fonacan Turkey.
OK.
Fonacan Turkey, I was a sand to communications.
We learned how to repair radios.
And it was for all my vehicles.
So I ended up going to an all-more unit when I was out there.
We went to Germany.
So it was about all my communication training.
And you sent over to West Germany.
I went to what they call Hobbit Barracks, which
is in Kissing Germany.
And that's where I spent the 20-day months
of my service time there.
So over two years, it gets around rough to an area.
It gets rough.
And so now, not only you're not in Toronto County,
earlier, your mom was rude, but you're not
even in the United States anymore, right?
Was it a shot?
No.
No more than the coach.
Matter of fact, when we were in basic training,
I'd blown back up the step.
There were 20 more or so young white guys who
were going to OCS Offices Training School.
And they were acting as squad leaders and those kind
of things.
And I was in basic training unit.
And my immediate squad leader said to me
when he had a 17-year-old brother.
He said, I wish he was anything like you want.
He could not do this.
He said, but he's your 17.
And you're doing this.
You're not crying.
You're not calling home.
You're not wanting.
He said, my keep brother couldn't do this.
He said, I wish he could see you and see how well
you're handling this.
And get into Germany.
Somebody was always there.
I tell KSC's, if you're respectful, you're honest,
and kind, people look after you.
And everywhere I went, there was always an older person who
said, we're going to take care of you.
Because they saw how young I was.
And they make sure that nothing happened to me.
So that was my German experience.
And did you get out and travel much while you were overseas?
No, it didn't travel much in Germany.
Obviously reasons.
Did speak the language with your own head.
I've been from a larger city.
And used to those kind of things.
I made a travel movement.
I didn't.
I went to Frankfurt in Newhamburg.
Cup time.
That was pretty much.
Extend my travel.
Did you hear much while you were overseas?
Or you were stationed over in Germany?
Did you hear much about what was going on back home, either
in Sassan or in the area in southwest Georgia,
or even with the movement as a whole?
Not a lot.
Not a whole lot.
The letters home were basically a band.
A motorcycle, a semi-boxes cake, and pecans, and peanuts.
And those kind of things that I couldn't get there.
That's pretty much it.
Not a lot of the information about the news
what was going on back home.
In the movement.
So you do about 2.5 years or so.
You come out.
And you come back home.
Yes.
Had much changed since you had been gone?
I remember being all about the likes and those kind of things.
Wow.
This is what I left.
Got home.
Things had changed a little bit.
They were talked about integrating the schools
and those kind of things.
But there were not a lot of economic that had changed.
And that was the biggest shock.
There's not a lot of economic that changed.
I had changed.
I would not do with some of the things I had
had been doing before.
I wanted more out of life.
And that's what changed most, you know,
surrounded that much.
Well, except for my father built another house on the spot
that we had no house.
But we were the, I think probably the first on the street
actually having to enter the bathroom.
But you say you had.
So some things had changed.
Right.
I mean, your family's the way you live
and how you live in that had changed.
But you say you had changed.
What changed you?
Well, when you go other places and you
talk to other people, they're doing different things.
Like, you know, you meet guys from Shire Town and the
motor city and, you know, those kind of things.
And they're talking about what they did.
I got introduced to jazz.
Matter of fact, I, the friend of mine that I met
that introduced me to jazz.
I actually saw him for the one years later,
last year, for the first time since he left Germany.
So, you know, I got introduced to jazz.
Basically, it's a country where you Western music and rock
and roll, the rock and roll, the type of bridge.
Never heard of jazz.
And I got introduced to jazz for these people,
those kinds of things.
And talking about what they did there and what was available
there, of course, not all of it was true.
But, you know, it gave you something to look forward to.
Yeah.
So I needed, I knew I needed an education to get
that done.
And so you come back home.
Why did you choose to come back to Tell of County?
It was home.
And I needed to do that.
I had actually, as you asked me there,
because my brother was in Detroit at the time
with my father's brothers and sisters.
And he was waiting for me to come to Detroit.
My mother's youngest brother that she raised
would live in the infill of the neighborhood,
his father and I, he wanted me to come to the infill of the neighborhood.
So I actually, he'd go to the infill of the neighborhood with him.
But I came, that's what I got to go home.
So I ended up in Dosa.
I applied for college at the Tennessee State.
And I had been accepted, but I would have had
to wait until January to get into college.
And I'll be in the state, we wouldn't
have taken me in September.
So I was afraid if I waited the other three months
that I may not attend, so I came to other state.
And then you, you want to stay in that?
For four years.
Now, all these state had been a hotbed of student protests
just a few years earlier.
What was the climate like when you came back, when you enrolled?
It was relatively quiet.
I mean, there were a couple of instances
where some of the students went across the bridge with me.
But I wasn't involved in that because I wasn't on campus.
But I heard about it.
But it was relatively quiet, but a few little things here and there.
What happened?
Did you stay at home?
And, or where did you live?
I lived at home for the first quarter.
And then I moved to all of the way with my homeboy, lived here.
So we got a little apartment down on the killing.
And that's when I stayed until I graduated.
And what did you major in?
Sociology.
But why did you do so?
Did quite know what I wanted to do.
And that was kind of an image-wean degree.
I really was touring with going to law school.
So Sociology was kind of an offshoot that I just took
because I didn't know what that's all about.
What was all many like the city, the town,
while you were a student?
Still safe, you ate it, but you could pretty much go
where you wanted to go within reason.
There weren't any big clues.
I didn't think that kind of thing.
It was still safe to get it.
And we had black police for that time, of course,
downtown.
I remember having a conversation with one of them at one point.
But it was still pretty much the south.
That's the point.
Have a confrontation.
Or run in with the black police?
Yeah, with the black police.
People would know if the traffic lights had had run the light.
I said, didn't.
He said, we ran away.
That's where, from where I said, the light was still heading.
The caution light had just come on when I had 100.
So after a few minutes, he didn't go to the gate.
But that was on the confrontation.
Was your dad still working in Albany at the time?
Yes.
He was still working at S. Will's.
Would you see him at all?
Yeah, I would go to the plant.
And when he worked, when he worked, there were, well,
they made fertilizer.
And I couldn't see him until I got rid of all of him.
It was so much dust in the place.
And that was a condition that he worried about.
He worried about extreme conditions.
But he didn't have the education.
So he had the work where he could get a job.
You said you had some uncles who had an uncle and a filth
of the doctor.
So you had family outside of the South.
Yes.
But your father and your mother, they never
thought about leaving.
Yes, my father did.
My mother did.
She told me that he wanted to move the drawer with brother
whoever she wouldn't go.
So he stayed to.
When was your mother's reason behind not wanting to leave?
I remember saying something.
He was not going to take her to Detroit
and put her in an upstairs apartment.
And that was about the extent where she said about it.
Who was your father's interest in leaving?
Why didn't you want to go?
There's brothers were there.
And brothers and sisters were there except for two
that was to hear with the rest of their way in Detroit.
How they got there, I really don't know.
We never discussed how they ended up there.
So I read them how they got there.
That's what they were.
You wanted to go.
Looking back at your college experience,
because eventually you will go after college.
You will head up to Michigan to Clinton, right?
But before you get there, looking back at your college,
the time you spent here, was it good?
I enjoyed college.
Well, let me say this.
Every semester I say, I'm not going back.
Because I worked two-poin-time jobs.
And a lot of times I would be too tired to study.
And a test would be test time.
And I said, I mean, I got it.
And then I ended up cramming for tests.
So I said, I'm not going back.
And then I would get through the test, OK.
And then I'd be satisfied.
I would go back and reach two again.
But it was always hard at that time.
So I enjoyed college.
But I didn't get to participate in a lot of the excretive
activities because I had to work.
So homecoming, weakly basketball games,
maybe I have seen a half-time of one game, maybe one homecoming.
Because I worked every weekend.
So every time homecoming was, I was on a set.
And I was solo-set, and I had to work.
So I didn't get to attend.
So you finished up your earned-year degree in sociology.
And you had a flint, Michigan.
Why flint?
Doug said it was a very good friend of mine.
We grew up pretty much in the church together.
His dad was a deconent church in my love.
And he even wanted ones that were present
the night the chair came in.
He and I were friends with high school.
But before that, I had gotten the job
to reach real estate prison recruited by the state of Georgia.
And where's that?
No, region.
It's out towards Savannah.
It's west, east of here.
It's east of here.
Going towards Savannah.
But anyway, I got recruited to work
in what they call an ex-offender program as a counselor.
And the warden saw me.
The first day told me, say, I don't get rid of you.
And my statement, it was whatever makes you happy.
And for much time, I was going.
So the warden didn't want you there.
No.
I was the first black to go there as anything
other than any makeup.
I didn't work for the prison system.
I worked for the state of Georgia, the labor department.
And I all who was actually across street from the camp.
But we had to go over to the chapel to do our interviews.
And I don't know what this problem was.
I mean, people are afraid.
Some of the people were, yeah, I don't know what this problem
will be told me.
And get rid of you.
Full much time, I was gone.
So Doug has been down.
He worked for General Motors at the time,
doing recruiting for General Motors.
So he graduated from Fort Valley State.
And doing the time he was here, we got together.
He said, man, we should go out to sleep.
I'm in Flint.
You know, it's come on to sleep.
You're not going to be doing the thing.
There's some in a way.
And I just don't have to graduate.
Yes.
OK.
I just lost a job at Reesfield.
So I might do it.
And I really didn't give a thought.
I really had no intention of driving that far.
Because it's flat.
It's about 15 hours, I think, north of you.
But after the job thing happened, I remember.
They told me I'd come to sleep.
So I went to the water and found this phone.
I'm calling.
Yeah, come on up.
So I left home.
I had my dad had signed for me to get us.
1966 Malibu, Chevalier-Malibu, Dark Loop.
And I got in a car with about $80 in my pocket.
And I drove to Flint.
And I stayed there with him for about a month, I guess he said.
Right?
You're not going home.
Why don't you start looking for a job?
So they worked.
So they called around some of the plastic
that I started doing interviews.
And I told them, and where did you begin working?
At Sheffield Truck Assembly.
At General Motors.
And where was it?
In Flint, in Flint, which is actually.
And what were you doing?
I started out in town keeping the initiative
to the Academy of Farming.
And one day I went in and resigned.
Now how long did you work in before you?
And we truck assembly, I think, a year.
And I went into the computer room to operate computers.
And they assigned me to a desk, doing accounts payables.
And this is the fun thing.
There were two other black girls that came from Mississippi
that they had recruited.
They were after accounting majors.
And I did not have an amazing accounting.
So it's other major but I mean accounting.
So it really wasn't your award.
And all I heard from the older women there,
ooh, I went with it right in the blaze.
My son, Meredith, sorry.
My son, Meredith Law, she's so lazy.
And oh, I got the most beautiful grandchild.
And those are the kind of conversation
that would all be having all day long.
And I just one day I couldn't take it in one of them.
So I wrote a two line of resolution
and gave it to the comfort of them.
And so do you stay up in Flint there?
I stay in Flint.
And leaving Flint that they around
knew I went downtown in Doug that started
to work for Equivalent Life Insurance Company.
And I remember that he said he worked in the mine building.
So I was just having to be in downtown.
I said, oh, that's the mine building.
I go see my man's here.
Well, I'm stairs.
And we sat down just like we were talking and,
Jimmy said, what are you doing downtown?
And she's supposed to be at work.
I said, I quit today.
And you know, the coast is my drop, over there.
You quit your job, you.
Call his manager, you interviewed me and hired me.
Right there.
Right there to sell insurance.
You were unemployed for about five hours.
I tried to death.
Yeah, about five hours.
So he hired me to sell insurance.
And the coasts do it so I had to train me.
So I sold the insurance for about three years for Equivalent Life.
And one of you, the campaign trips,
and got pretty good at it actually.
And when I decided to move back to Atlanta,
then I went back to Zierre Motors because that worked for them
before to get a transfer room.
So that's how I got to Atlanta.
And I had a job when I got there.
And where were we working in Atlanta?
War for General's Atlanta.
OK.
At what plant?
Durable.
Right in North of Atlanta.
Yes.
North of Atlanta.
That's what we can tell I was involved in the Herald Collision
in the 1795 and they were tied me up with it.
So you worked at the Durable plant for 20 years,
but it worked for 20 years.
And where were you living at the time?
In Durable.
In the Cape.
Atlanta's a little different than Terrell County.
Even in the 70s and 80s.
What was that experience like?
Didn't like the traffic, but it was a place to be.
I really wanted to be here.
And I actually came back a couple of times
to find the job and precious took me back.
But it was OK.
It was a place to live, a place to work.
And every chance I got out, came home.
And, matter of fact, one year I came home
even a week in.
For whole year.
That's how much I liked Atlanta.
But it was OK.
It was a place to live.
And so then after the accident, you were tired in Durable.
And you come back.
You do move back to Terrell County.
So now you're back home.
I had asked you before, had home changed much when you had
gone away to the war.
You said it had changed that much.
When you come back from Atlanta, had home changed much.
Not really.
Not economically.
People were still following.
They still, they weren't sharecrubbing anymore.
They were business farmers now.
And they were hiring blacks to drive tractors and pay
them by the month that kind of thing.
So it was different.
Because during the movement, they told out
all the ragged houses, they had the shakes and ran the black
ball off because they were asking to register the vote.
So that way they would get rid of them.
So they ended up having to come business farmers,
having to buy machinery, that kind of thing.
So cotton pickers, peanut come by,
those kind of things were more prevalent than what I remember.
The mutant wagon was gone.
When I was growing up, people plied,
the field was immune.
And we were growing on a wagon with mutants.
But after that, it was like trucks, tractors,
those kind of things, use a farming.
And one or two of the industries we need,
but pretty much the same.
Economic is still depressed.
How about politically?
I mean, was there, I mean, now people
were able to register the vote?
That was still a problem with that.
I mean, there was still ways found to make it difficult.
Yeah, more people were registered.
There were blacks here and there that had gotten offices.
But it was pretty much the same.
I didn't see it in real outstanding changes.
Let's put it that way.
My brother liked to make the statement,
really doesn't matter who's driving the wagon.
It's always going to be in the same place.
And that's pretty much what the weight is, really.
Submarine, we've covered a lot.
And you share a lot.
Is there anything that you would like to add
that we skipped over?
We can do a lot more things now than we are with the,
even in small towns.
You're not threatened just for walking streets.
You don't see the white, black water
perfountance or whites in this door, blacks in that door.
You don't see that kind of separation.
But we're still separate.
So on the surface, we look at it.
We look at it.
It appears that we have really gained a lot.
But sometimes I want to really how much of it.
We really have gained because behind the scenes,
things still haven't changed much.
I can remember a guy asking me when I went to Flint.
What difference did I see between the South and the North?
And I asked him, I said, you really want to ask?
He said, yeah, I want you to ask.
I said, you sure?
So yes.
I said, well, it's like this.
Here, I'm even visiting your house, maybe having me with you.
And then when I leave, you probably break the plate
of the glass that I use.
There, I already knew I'm not going to be invited.
So I understand more about where my position is.
Not like that.
Quite like that.
So I don't have to question whether you like me.
And I know you don't.
So I don't have to expose myself to you.
Well, he got mad at me.
He didn't speak to me at all.
But that's the difference I see between North and South.
There's a perceived freedom.
But it really is not there sometimes.
It's perceived.
But on the heath is really not.
In a lot of ways, I like to South better
because I don't have to question.
I don't have to expose myself.
I already know where I'm accepted there pretty much.
And it's up to me whether or not I want to venture past
that or not.
But that, you kind of give that false security
that you can do these things.
And that's the difference I see between South and North.
And there is more economic separation
than it is white, black separation here.
You just, it's just a difference in the race here.
But there, if you don't have the money
and the way they separate there, they just take the money,
go to suburb with them.
And it's happening here.
We have, we asked about conditions.
We have black mayors, but the economics are gone.
The base for support and the city,
they're gone to suburb attacks.
Yeah.
So you can't be aware of it, but if you don't have money.
And then we'll accuse of not being good stewards.
But how can you be in the city in a town?
Yeah.
How can you be a good student?
You don't have a pause-up rate.
The infrastructure is gone.
You know, people complain about the stand-up.
But there's nothing money there.
I mean, the tax base is gone.
So you can't read it very, very, very.
Oh, it's a round.
Thank you very much.
This is no wonderful.
Keep it right.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture.